there's so many visually stunning
sequences in this film um is there one
moment in particular that you think are
going to blow fans away in IMAX what do
you think I think the train sequence I
think train sequence is is is
extraordinary and will be extraordinary
in IMAX there's also a particularly
colorful sequence with lots of smoke
which we will not mention in too much
detail which I think will also be
incredible an yeah yeah I agree I would
love to kind of hear your insights
behind the scenes of that and then
seeing like what you guys thought of the
final version of that sequence uh we
shot the thing with the stunt team and
then they'd edit it together in their
own way and then Matthew would see it
then we change stuff and so we had a
vague idea of how these things turn out
and the real work went into obviously
the stun team building thing in the
first place but then Sam and I trying to
match each other physically while
maintaining the individuality of our of
our characters